SPEAKER 1: And I'm very excited
to welcome our guests here
today.
This is really awesome.
Quick intros-- so
we're chatting today
about "Nancy," which is WNYC
Studios' LGBTQ-themed podcast
about how we define ourselves
and the journey that we
take to get there.
And my guests are
Tobin Low and Kathy Tu.
And prior to "Nancy,"
Tobin was a producer--
I'm going to just
read this out so
that, you know, I don't
mess it up, because I will.
Prior to "Nancy,"
Tobin was a producer
on WNYC Studios'
"More Perfect," which
was a "Radiolab" spinoff
about the Supreme Court.
His work has also appeared on
"Marketplace," "Studio 360,"
and "The Codebreaker" podcast.
He is the recipient of a 2015
STEM Story Grant from PRX,
and was a New Voices scholar at
the 2014 Third Coast Festival
Conference.
Tobin was once a professional
cellist and attended a circus
camp as a child, fun fact.
TOBIN LOW: All true.
KATHY TU: All true.
SPEAKER 1: Kathy heads
up "Nancy's" West
Coast operations, AKA
her home in Los Angeles.
Prior to "Nancy," Kathy
did production work
for a number of podcasts,
including "The Memory Palace,"
"The Mortified Podcast,"
and "Masterpiece Studio."
And she would like it to be
noted that this whole hosting
thing makes her
very uncomfortable,
but she's leaning the F in.
So thank you so much for coming.
Thank you so much
for being here.
This is really wonderful.
I know we have some fans of
the podcast in the audience.
Yes?
[CHEERING]
Yes.
Great.
So I'm just going to jump
right in with a few questions.
I'm curious what precipitated
the creation of "Nancy,"
the podcast.
KATHY TU: Where do
you want to start?
TOBIN LOW: I'm not
just pandering here.
It started with a Google doc.
KATHY TU: It did.
TOBIN LOW: Hey!
[LAUGHTER]
KATHY TU: That's true.
SPEAKER 1: That's amazing.
TOBIN LOW: So Kathy and I met--
I guess three years
ago at this point--
at a program called The
Transom Story Workshop.
It's like a boot camp
for people wanting
to get into Public Radio.
KATHY TU: Four years ago.
TOBIN LOW: Four years ago.
And we just immediately
latched on to each other.
And we're, like, we need
to work together somehow.
And it came up that we loved
this sort of "This American
Life," "Radiolab" style
of radio storytelling.
But we didn't
really see a program
that was applying that to queer
stories, like to LGBT stories.
KATHY TU: Right.
TOBIN LOW: So we were, like,
we should just make that.
We should figure out
a way to do that.
And at the time, we were just
going to do it on our own.
We were going to freelance it.
KATHY TU: On the side.
TOBIN LOW: Right.
And we did what we always did
when we were procrastinating
on a thing, which is you
start a shared Google doc,
and that makes you
feel like you're
getting the ball rolling,
like we're being productive.
It's happening.
KATHY TU: Let's
write some words.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: I see you updating.
I'm updating.
The magic is happening.
And then it just so happened
that maybe two weeks after we
decided we were going
to do this on our own,
WNYC opened up an open
call for podcast ideas.
So we ended up pitching to
them in a "Shark Tank" style.
We had five minutes on a stage
at a journalism conference
to pitch them our idea.
KATHY TU: Yeah, and there was a
clock that was counting down--
TOBIN LOW: Right.
KATHY TU: --our five minutes.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
KATHY TU: It was terrifying.
I blacked out for
the whole thing.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: But-- so out of
that, we ended up winning.
And we got a pilot with WNYC.
And we developed it with them
for about a year, or like,
a couple months.
And then we got
greenlit out of that.
And that is "Nancy."
KATHY TU: Here we are.
SPEAKER 1: Amazing, that
sounds like an intense start
to a podcast.
So what are your goals
for the podcast overall?
Do you have particular goals
in mind for putting this out
into the world?
KATHY TU: I feel like I always
say my goal for the podcast
is for people to
feel-- especially
people in the LGBT community--
to feel like they're
connected to something.
They hear different voices.
And they're not
stuck in their corner
of whichever part of the
community that they're in.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
TOBIN LOW: I think we talked a
lot about moments where people
see something or read something
where they feel really
seen or recognized.
And so in a lot of
ways, the podcast
has a very simple
thought behind it,
which is like, as
many people as we can,
if we can give them that moment,
that would be really great.
KATHY TU: Yeah, and you
said something recently
about the podcast.
You said that you wanted it to
be the defender of queer joy.
TOBIN LOW: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
KATHY TU: That.
I think that that is kind
of what we're aiming for.
SPEAKER 1: So how do you
decide which topics to cover?
KATHY TU: There are so
many topics to cover.
SPEAKER 1: So many topics.
And you've already
covered quite a few.
KATHY TU: It's a balancing act
of what stories get pitched
to us, what stories
we find interesting,
what stories are
happening right now,
the opportunities
we have to capture
somebody trying to figure out
a thing which we love to do.
It's a giant balancing act.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
I think there's a
lot of stuff that we
want to cover that's sort
of on this mental list
that we keep going,
of, we really
want to cover this
and this and this.
But we also made a
hard rule for ourselves
that nobody on the show
would ever just be coming on
to define themselves.
Do you know what I mean?
We try really hard
not to have anyone
on who's just this is who I am,
and I'm defining my identity
for a larger audience.
So a lot of times it's
waiting for the right story
or the right interview
that will get at things
in an interesting way.
And so sometimes that's
the bar for something
getting on the show.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And do you feel
like that is what makes--
like, what do you feel
makes "Nancy" unique?
Because there are obviously
other LGBTQ-focused podcasts.
But there is clearly
a unique angle.
What do you feel that that is?
KATHY TU: I think it's that we
both love narrative stories,
I don't know, more
than interviews.
But there are times when I just
want to listen to a narrative
story just because I don't have
to think too much about it,
if that makes sense.
Like, sometimes I listen
to an interview that
does a really deep
dive into something,
and that's fascinating.
But that gets me a little
bit tired at the end.
And sometimes it's
sort of like, I
don't know, watching
good television.
You just sort of sit and
you let them entertain you.
And that's what I like about
narrative-driven stories,
the fact that we can
tell a story featuring
queer people living
their lives or whatever
they're going through.
And I can sit back and
just let it entertain me.
Does that make sense?
Did I answer a question?
OK.
SPEAKER 1: But you
also aside from having
folks come on and talk during
your show or be interviewed,
you also share a fair
number of personal stories
and anecdotes on the show.
What is your
process for deciding
how and when you share
that personal information
[? to a ?] wide audience?
TOBIN LOW: Uh.
KATHY TU: Hm.
TOBIN LOW: If my therapist
tells me that it's interesting--
I literally just had my
therapist pitch me on a thing.
It was very bizarre.
I was, like, I don't
want to talk about that.
Or like, I don't know what
to talk about on the show.
And she was, like,
I can think of five
things you should talk about.
[LAUGHTER]
So when we first
started the show,
and we were working
on our pilot,
Kathy had been sitting
on this amazing tape
where she came out to her mom--
KATHY TU: Again.
TOBIN LOW: --again.
And it was this
really amazing tape
of the experience of
coming out specifically
to an immigrant mother.
And how are you dealing
with both translation
in a literal sense,
but also in the divide
of what her experience is
versus your experience?
So even when we didn't
know what the show was,
we knew that that
was great tape.
We knew that that
was a great story.
So I feel a lot of us
digging into personal stuff
has tumbled out of Kathy's first
story being really personal
and people really
responding to that.
And so now we have cursed
ourselves forever more--
KATHY TU: I know.
TOBIN LOW: --to be spilling
things out on the show.
KATHY TU: Every time I feel
anxious about something,
I feel like our boss is, like,
maybe do a story on that.
And I'm, like, dammit.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
KATHY TU: Here we go.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
Also you have started
season two, very exciting.
How do you feel you shaped
season two differently from how
you shaped season one?
Or did you shape it
differently, or is it more
of a continuation of the same?
TOBIN LOW: I feel like
it's a continuation.
Because we always knew that
we had sort of, like, 12
episodes in season one.
And we were very
aware that you're not
going to get to 12 episodes
and be, like, we did it.
We've covered all the stories
KATHY TU: All of
them have been told.
TOBIN LOW: So, yeah, it
feels like season two is just
an opportunity to do
more of the storytelling
that we wanted to do.
I will say the difference is
that we have an audience base,
and we want to start
figuring out how
we interact with that audience.
And so that was the
drive behind this project
we're doing called Out
at Work, which is, like--
SPEAKER 1: That was going
to be my next question.
TOBIN LOW: Oh, cool.
SPEAKER 1: Tobin's
actually a mind reader.
Actually, another fun fact.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
Yeah, OK, so Out at
Work is this big project
we're doing that
has to do with some
of the big legal stuff
about what protections
we do and don't have as LGBT
workers in this country.
But it also sort of boils
down to the everyday stories
of, like, are you your
coworker's token gay friend?
And do they ask
you-- but we just
had a guy on this
week's episode who
talks about because
he's out at work,
everyone assumes
that he just wants
to talk about sex all the time.
And they're coming to him
with all their sex stories.
And he's, like, I just
want this to be my job.
But you know, there's
real stories like that,
just interacting with coworkers
and that kind of thing.
And I think we're really
interested in having listeners
of this show share
their stories with us
and sort of get into how
that's really fascinating story
territory for us.
So yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, so
this is obviously
an area that is of
interest, I think.
I mean, the entire podcast is
of interest to this community.
But the Out at Work piece
for many of us who are out,
some of us very,
very out, super out,
I think that these are really
relevant and timely stories
to be telling.
So can you tell us
a little bit more
about what precipitated
the project
and how you're
thinking about it now
that you're starting to dive in?
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
Do you want me to do it?
KATHY TU: Yes, please.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: Well, truthfully
part of it was inspired by--
I don't know if anyone listens
to "Death, Sex, and Money"?
It's another podcast.
So they just did a big project
where they asked people
about their student
loans, and they
got an incredible
outpouring of people
just being, like,
here's the thing
that I experience in my
life all the time having
to deal with student loans.
But it's, like, I have to
deal with it by myself.
It's a thing that
touches a lot of us,
but that we don't
talk about that much.
And so part of it
was thinking about,
OK, we have a very
engaged LGBT audience.
What's a thing that
affects a lot of them,
but we don't necessarily
make the time
to talk about or dig into?
And pretty immediately,
we started joking,
our jobs are bizarre,
because being gay
is like we are
professional gays.
Like, it's in the
title of what we do.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
TOBIN LOW: But that for most
people, it's not that way.
And most people have to
navigate being queer at work
and how much they share and
how much they don't share
and that that can be
a complicated thing
and a funny thing
and an awkward thing.
And any time there's a
lot of emotions and stuff,
we're, like, there's
probably stories there,
and we should talk about them.
And this is probably a good
moment to plug that you guys
should go to
NancyPodcast.org/Work,
and fill out our survey, and
share stories if you have them,
because we are actively mining
for them now to possibly put
them on the show.
KATHY TU: Yeah, and our producer
Matt will call you and record
you at some point--
probably, I don't know.
TOBIN LOW: Oh, this
is a good moment
to say Matt our producer
wanted me to say a thing,
and I don't know what
these words mean,
but he wants you to
bring back Google Reader.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHY TU: Oh!
Yes, I also agree.
Can we talk about this?
Why did it go away?
TOBIN LOW: Raise your hand
if you can do something
about Google Reader.
SPEAKER 1: No?
TOBIN LOW: No, OK.
KATHY TU: No?
Nothing has replaced it.
I've tried them all.
OK, sorry.
SPEAKER 1: No ex-Google
Reader staff in here?
No, no, I'm sorry.
TOBIN LOW: Was it like a--
SPEAKER 1: Very
sadly struck out.
TOBIN LOW: It's
like a book thing?
KATHY TU: No, it allowed you
to subscribe to different blogs
and news and stuff.
And then it just all shows
up in front on your page.
And then you can just
mark the ones you've read.
It was so great.
TOBIN LOW: I don't need that.
KATHY TU: It was a
great [INAUDIBLE]..
TOBIN LOW: It's fine.
KATHY TU: Now they just spam
you with all these emails.
TOBIN LOW: I take it back.
You can leave it.
SPEAKER 1: Now we're all
listening to podcasts.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So I wanted to talk
about representation quickly.
And how you go
through the process,
particularly with
the folks that you
choose to bring on the show.
And I know that there
was a discussion, which
I won't dive too deeply
in, in case anybody hasn't
heard the discussion yet.
But there's conversations
about the responses
that you've received from
fans about bi representation
or other pieces of the
LGBTQQIAAPP acronym
that are or are not represented.
So I'm curious how
you're approaching--
how you're approaching that.
KATHY TU: Again, it's a
huge balancing act between--
we don't just think about that.
We also think about
race and location
and socioeconomic status.
There's a lot of things we
try to pack-- well, not pack.
But we try to spread out our
stories as much as we can.
But I feel like
a lot of times we
get pitched stories
from the coasts,
and it's hard to
wade through those
to find other stories from
the Midwest, from the South,
just to get more diverse
voices onto the show.
And I think that's one
of the reasons why we're
doing the Out at Work project
so that we can get more people,
more voices onto the podcast.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah, it's
a challenge, though.
Because inherently, we did
set a very wide net for what
we said the show would
be about, and so that
covers a lot of people who have
been waiting for their story
to be told anywhere.
You know what I mean?
Like, when somebody
comes at you and says,
I'm a fan of the show.
Please do a story
about x, y, or z.
You have to take that in.
Because that is somebody who is
waiting for their story to be
told.
And that is something that
we are endeavoring to do.
So there is this relationship
with the audience where
you have to take in
that kind of criticism
and be like, yep, you are right.
We are going to do
our best, and we
are going to try and find a way
to do that in a smart way that
serves the story well.
So yeah, it's tough.
SPEAKER 1: Speaking of fans and
your audience, which episodes--
since you are having this
sort of back and forth
with your audience, and
they're sending you letters
and giving you feedback--
which episodes elicited
the strongest responses?
TOBIN LOW: "Harry Potter."
KATHY TU: "Harry Potter."
TOBIN LOW: By far--
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Can you tell us
a little bit about that?
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
KATHY TU: Well,
our producer Matt
is a giant "Harry Potter" fan.
And he also loves going down the
rabbit holes like nerd raging.
And the thing that he
enjoys nerd raging about
is the fact that Dumbledore
is not actually gay.
You can't just after the
fact say that he's gay.
And so he did an
episode about this,
and people were
just upset about it.
TOBIN LOW: They were pissed.
KATHY TU: They were mad.
And they were
attacking JK Rowling.
TOBIN LOW: So mad.
KATHY TU: And I'm, like--
TOBIN LOW: Yeah,
and it was funny,
too, because like either one
or two episodes before it,
I think before it--
we had done an episode
about gay Republicans, which
we were expecting that one
to be very controversial.
And it was to a certain degree.
We did get some pushback
and some tweets and stuff.
But then the "Harry Potter"
came out and just blew it out
of the water.
People were furious.
KATHY TU: They're
like, how dare you?
SPEAKER 1: How dare you
question Dumbledore's queerness?
KATHY TU: How dare we
question Rowling, I think.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah, well, so
I think if you actually
listen to the episode, it's
like a tongue in cheek,
but also interesting
conversation
about representation and
what does it actually
mean to tell someone's
story and not just do
like the lip service
of, like, by the way,
this person is queer.
We did it.
We told a queer story.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
TOBIN LOW: So I
think that that's
what the episode was about.
But there were a lot of people
who saw a headline and were,
like oh, you are
calling out JK Rowling.
I'm going to tweet
at her and see if we
can get this going online.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Get this going?
Meaning, like, start a fight?
TOBIN LOW: Like have
her yell at us, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Wow!
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
KATHY TU: Actually that would
have been great if she had done
that, but she didn't.
SPEAKER 1: OK, were
there any other--
so you said the "Harry Potter"
episode as well as the--
I'm assuming they were
the Log Cabin Republicans?
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: OK, so were
there any other episodes
that elicited
surprising responses,
either positive or negative?
KATHY TU: Surprising responses.
I guess I wasn't
surprised by this,
but when I announced
that I was watching
"The L Word," people were, like,
I don't know, they freaked out.
I don't know why.
Because I'd never seen it?
I don't know.
TOBIN LOW: Well,
I think that was
one of the episodes
where we were, like, this
is going to be a niche episode.
Like, some people will
stand really hard for this,
and other people will skip it.
But the passion that
came out, I mean,
people have a lot of
feelings about "The L Word."
SPEAKER 1: So many feelings,
I have so many feelings.
KATHY TU: I really [INAUDIBLE].
TOBIN LOW: Wait, so who
has watched "The L Word?"
Anyone?
A couple people?
She loves Jenny.
She is Team Jenny.
SPEAKER 1: I'm sorry.
You need to get out.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: And-- yeah.
The last panel we
were on, this came up.
And it ended up, like, we
didn't talk about anything
else for 20 minutes.
Because people were so
mad that she liked Jenny.
KATHY TU: Usually there's
one Jenny supporter
in the audience.
SPEAKER 1: How far through
the series are you?
[LAUGHTER]
KATHY TU: I finished
it, and I decided
at the end that
Team Jenny, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: [DRAMATIC EXHALE]
[LAUGHTER]
KATHY TU: I know.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
TOBIN LOW: Wait, are
there any "Buffy" watchers
in the audience?
KATHY TU: Oh, you
want to go this--
TOBIN LOW: OK, she also
loves Faith, which is--
AUDIENCE: That's fine.
KATHY TU: Thank you!
TOBIN LOW: No!
TOBIN LOW: I think
that is insane.
KATHY TU: He doesn't count
the Angel arc, which,
like, is like, what?
It's the same Buffyverse.
TOBIN LOW: There
have to be rules.
There have to be rules.
KATHY TU: Faith all the way.
TOBIN LOW: You like
Faith, and that is nuts.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHY TU: I also like Willow.
But who doesn't?
Who doesn't?
TOBIN LOW: It's like
saying I like bread.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHY TU: What kind of bread?
TOBIN LOW: Oprah bread.
SPEAKER 1: Mm, bread.
OK.
All right, so "The L
Word," "Harry Potter"--
these are all pretty
juicy topics that
could fill many, many hours.
But you have to cut them down
to 20 to 25 minutes, right?
Are there any topics--
I mean, I feel like if you can
fit "The L Word" and "Harry
Potter" into 20, 25
minutes, you're super human
and can probably fit anything
into 20 or 25 minutes.
But are there any
topics that you did not
feel you could cover in
that short of a time?
KATHY TU: I think so.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
I would say if there
are, we're probably
still trying to
find a way to do it
and probably
shouldn't say anymore.
KATHY TU: Oh, OK.
TOBIN LOW: No, I don't know.
KATHY TU: I was going to say
like things that require deep,
investigative journalism.
I don't that we have the
capacity yet to do it,
but maybe one day in the future.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah, we're still
figuring that part out,
I think.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome, so for
the pieces of pop culture
that you dive into, do
you feel as though these
require careful consideration,
the pieces of pop culture?
I was looking here, we've
got "The Golden Girls."
Again, "Harry Potter"
comes up pretty strongly.
How do you tell stories
about pop culture?
Because often I
think that we find
that pop culture has a
particular heteronormative
skew.
So how do you feel
you address some
of-- well, heteronormative
and many other normative, very
normative skew.
But how do you address
issues of pop culture?
And do you find yourselves
conflicted in addressing
some of those things?
KATHY TU: I feel
conflicted all the time,
especially working
on these stories.
Well, things like "The Golden
Girls," for pop culture
stories, I think we try to find
an angle that hasn't really
been seen before.
Like, for "Golden Girls,"
we were looking at the--
what did you call it?
Like, the fandom
around it and what that
meant to people who are queer,
even though the show wasn't
explicitly queer.
And we found different
stories about how the show
itself had affected us.
Instead of doing the
deep dive into making
that show and the actors
and whether or not
they liked each
other, even though I
know all of those stories, too.
But we couldn't talk
about those stories,
because they weren't relevant.
So yeah, I feel like we try
to find an angle that hasn't
really been covered before.
Do you agree?
TOBIN LOW: Yeah, well,
I think there's like--
it's funny.
I think pop culture,
like any of the stories
we do, we made a very
conscious decision early
on that no one on the
show would come on
as a quote, unquote
expert of anything,
that they would always
be coming from the angle,
like, this is my personal
relationship to this thing.
So I think when we were
developing "The Golden Girls"
episode or "The L
Word" episode, there
were moments where those
stories took the shape of, like,
here is a high level look
at what this show meant.
And then that felt
like kind of what
you were saying, like it
was trying to do too much.
And so when we buried
down, and it was, like,
oh, this episode is
actually more about
what people do with
fandom, or what
people do with something
that's not explicitly queer,
but they reinvent
it for themselves
or see it through
a different angle
and find that representation.
Like, that's the moment where
the pop culture episodes
sort of click for us, when it's
about something else, not just
the show, if that makes sense.
SPEAKER 1: Does
anybody have questions?
Does anybody want
to pop up to the mic
quickly and ask some
questions of your own?
Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: Kind of in the vein
of the Out at Work project,
we talked a lot about your
sort of audience response.
I'd be curious what the
professional response has been,
I'd say both from maybe other
podcasters and maybe folks
at WNYC, et cetera.
TOBIN LOW: Meaning, how have
they taken to the project?
AUDIENCE: How have they taken--
how have they've taken to
the podcast as a whole, sort
of, yeah, sort of yes,
I guess, in general.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
KATHY TU: Well, WNYC has
been super supportive.
And I feel like we're
very lucky to have
been able to pilot
this project with them,
because they let us take a
while to really figure out
what our sound was before we
released it into the wild.
And ever since
it's been out, I've
heard nothing but good
things from our coworkers.
Maybe they're just being
nice, I don't know.
TOBIN LOW: I mean,
public radio, admittedly,
is a very crunchy space.
So there is sort of
that support in there,
and a genuine
curiosity for people
to have their own space to talk
about identity and stuff that
traditionally in larger
media doesn't get talked
about or covered very much.
So I feel WNYC Studios has
been super supportive of us
and what we're trying to do.
And super supportive,
also, of the fact
that we have a very specific
audience that we're targeting.
We're not that interested in
my broadening this out into,
like--
KATHY TU: Yeah.
TOBIN LOW: I mean, we're not
very interested in targeting
this, like here's how we explain
queer culture to a larger
audience.
They were on board
with us being,
like, we are really interested
in targeting specifically
a queer audience.
And in the specificity
of that storytelling,
other people will show
up, too, because they
will feel they are
getting let into a world
that maybe they don't know
about and are curious about.
So that kind of support
has been really awesome.
The other thing I'll say,
which we were just realizing,
is it's kind of hard
to troll a podcast.
KATHY TU: I know.
TOBIN LOW: So somebody who
disagrees with your content
or doesn't like
queer people, let's
say, to troll a podcast they
would have to actually listen,
one, and then find a quote they
don't like, and then tweet us.
And then-- so the times
that that has happened
is lesser than people just
sort of expressing fandom.
So in that sense, I think WNYC
recognizes that podcasting
can be a great space for people
to really express exactly
what they want to talk about.
KATHY TU: Of course,
now when you say that,
and the trolls will actually--
TOBIN LOW: I know, I
just invited the trolls.
KATHY TU: I know.
But if we do get
negative messages,
it's always reacting
to some headline.
Nobody's actually heard it.
SPEAKER 1: Have
you had experiences
of people, the very few
who have trolled you,
actually listening
to the podcast
and having their minds changed?
It sounded like the people
who are trolling you had not--
it was pretty clear that
they had not listened.
KATHY TU: Mm.
TOBIN LOW: Oh, minds changed.
Well, I will say we got an email
very early on that the person
just sort of declared up top,
I'm a 55-year-old white cis
male, and I love your show.
And it helps me learn
about x, y, and z.
And our reaction was kind of
like, we were not expecting
you, sir, but welcome.
KATHY TU: Welcome.
Yeah, yeah, we get
a few of those.
SPEAKER 1: Got one more.
AUDIENCE: Apologies
if you already
answered this at the very
beginning of the talk.
But just wondering, how did you
guys decide on the name "Nancy"
for the podcast?
TOBIN LOW: Oh, good, good story.
KATHY TU: Pure frustration.
[LAUGHTER]
We originally pitched
the idea as "Gaydio,"
and then decided that-- well,
number one, it was taken.
But also we wanted our title to
be a little bit more inclusive
on the surface.
If it was just
"Gaydio," I think,
we didn't want to
alienate anybody that
doesn't respond to just gay.
So then we went through a
bunch of different puns, all
the queer puns.
None of them were right.
And then Tobin one
day was like, we're
just going to name
it after a person.
TOBIN LOW: Right.
There was a moment
where for a second
it seemed like a good idea to
name the show "Gay Ponies."
KATHY TU: Yeah.
That was great.
TOBIN LOW: And so we walked
around for a day being,
like, "Gay Ponies," right?
This is good?
Yes?
No?
OK.
And then we were, like--
and then truly in a moment
of frustration, I was, like,
let's just give it a human name.
And then we landed on
this idea that "Nancy" has
like a nod to queer culture.
It has this history as being a
term, like, a very old school
term for a gay man.
So we liked that it had this
almost like, friend of Dorothy
nod.
Like, if you know, you
know kind of thing.
And then we also liked that
there was a bit of reclaiming,
because I think Nancy,
historically, has
been sort of a negative term.
And so we liked
that we were going
to take it, and reclaim it,
and define it as something
new and fun and joyous.
So like-- and then
there was just
something irreverent
about naming a fucking
show after a person.
You know?
Like, Nancy, it was
kind of ridiculous.
So it ticked a lot of boxes for
us, and we thought it was fun.
KATHY TU: I'm not going to lie,
I wasn't on board initially,
but I trusted you.
[LAUGHTER]
I trusted you.
Jenny's fine.
AUDIENCE: So we touched
on this a little bit.
And I think one of
the things I really
appreciate about the
podcast, and what
sets it apart from something
like "This American Life"
is the personal disclosure
piece and a lot of the things
that you've unpacked
for the world to hear.
Where would you say
you've experienced
the most personal growth as a
result of that since the time
you started?
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
KATHY TU: Well, I
feel like that's
directed at me,
because I figured
a lot of stuff out via podcast.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Well, both of you--
I just listened to the pool
party, bathing suit episode.
So there's a lot--
KATHY TU: Yeah,
there's a lot of stuff.
I didn't really engage
with queer media
before this podcast started.
And as soon as Tobin and
I started working on this,
I was, like, oh my
god, I'm so behind.
And I did a deep dive into it.
But along the way, I feel
like through the podcast,
I would say, I'm coming
into who I think--
how I identify, and how I'm
presenting to the world.
And that's been
super beneficial.
I was driving with
Tobin in LA when
we were on vacation together.
[LAUGHS] And I told him
that I don't think I
would be where I am now had
this project not come to be.
Because I've worked
through a lot of stuff,
like coming out to my
mom, cutting my hair,
being OK with the
fact that I feel
a stigma towards a certain
word that I now don't really
anymore.
It's been like a
big step for me.
And then going to
an all queer space
that originally
I was very scared
to be in, because there's
too many queer people.
How do I even negotiate that?
And now I love it.
I'm going back [INAUDIBLE]
camp next year.
So it's been a huge--
do you feel like I'm growing?
Do you--
TOBIN LOW: Oh, yeah.
KATHY TU: OK.
TOBIN LOW: Every single day.
KATHY TU: He does learn a
thing about me every day.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
KATHY TU: [LAUGHS]
So yeah, that's
what the podcast
has done for me.
Eternally grateful, Tobin.
Eternally grateful.
TOBIN LOW: That's good.
KATHY TU: What about you?
Have you changed?
TOBIN LOW: Yeah, so for
me, I think the challenge
for me has been that I came
from a radio background
where I had been used to being
in more of a reporter seat.
So for "Marketplace"
or "More Perfect,"
it was like the
story is out here,
and I'm working on
it from a distance.
And so the piece of the
show where we are now
sort of diving into
our personal lives
and having to navigate
doing stories about that
is very new territory for me.
And something that I have
been reluctant to do,
but I think Kathy has
really set a tone for.
KATHY TU: Just dived
right in there.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: But
like, how to do it
in a smart way, where
it's not just like here's
all of my junk.
But also, like, here is my junk,
and what I learned from it,
and what you can hopefully
take a piece of also.
So I think in that way, I
have learned from Kathy.
Because she sort of set a tone
for that in how to do that.
I'm still figuring it out.
Still talking to my
therapist about it.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
TOBIN LOW: Hey, Michelle,
if she ever watches this.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: And Michelle
was like your hi, mom?
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So do we have
another question coming up?
Yeah?
All right, cool.
TOBIN LOW: I also just love that
this group is called Gayglers.
KATHY TU: I know.
TOBIN LOW: Is there-- like I
was pitching bad puns before,
so is the Swedish
Googlers called Guglers?
KATHY TU: He's got
more, you guys.
Wait for it.
TOBIN LOW: Women who date
younger men, are they Couglers?
[GROANS FROM AUDIENCE]
KATHY TU: Here we go.
Here we go.
TOBIN LOW: Feel free to take
any of these, by the way.
KATHY TU: You had another
one that was really good.
TOBIN LOW: Oh, I was, like, are
Halloween enthusiasts Googly
eyes?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: I love all of these.
I'm so glad we're
recording this,
so that we can have
this for posterity.
TOBIN LOW: Take them all.
Take them all.
AUDIENCE: I'm a big "Harry
Potter" fan, so definitely
had reactions to that one.
[LAUGHTER]
So the way I react to a lot of
the heteronormative, like books
and series, is fan fiction.
There's, like, big "Harry
Potter" and other series fan
fiction to make it queer.
And I wondered if you
had any reactions to that
with people being, like, OK,
but some person's random idea
explains why,
maybe, Dumbledore is
gay, like gives
him a background,
and, like, talks more
about his relationship.
Also "Harry Potter" and
"Voldemort" being in love fan
fiction is just, like, amazing.
KATHY TU: Is that true?
I didn't know that existed!
AUDIENCE: There's,
like, lots of stories
about "Harry Potter" and
Voldemort being in love
and how they take over
the world together.
KATHY TU: Recently, I've
been down the rabbit
hole about Rombledore, how
Ron is actually Dumbledore.
He goes back in time
and becomes Dumbledore.
[LAUGHTER]
I wish Matt was here.
He would really be into this.
TOBIN LOW: He would love this.
I will say, I think when Matt
was working on that story,
he did have a part of it
talking, more explicitly
talking about the really
rich fan fiction world that
has claimed "Harry Potter."
And then I think it's like what
we were talking about before,
like that felt like it
could deserve its own story.
And so to give it an
almost perfunctory nod
in this thing that was sort
of about just the books.
I think we felt,
like, oh, this is
a thing we should
return to and dive
into as it's own
thing, because it's
such an interesting world, what
people do with fan fiction.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
TOBIN LOW: So yeah, you
should definitely direct us
to what we should be reading.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I'll send you some.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah.
Please do.
KATHY TU: We know Matt.
He would love it.
SPEAKER 1: Jen, do
you have a question?
Nice.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Tobin.
TOBIN LOW: Hi, stranger.
AUDIENCE: So I know you from
a pretty different background
as a classical cellist.
And I'm curious sort of about
your experience growing up,
I think, thinking
that that was going
to be your life path, and the
transition that you made there.
KATHY TU: Hey, hold on.
First question-- do
you have a good Tobin
story from his cellist days?
AUDIENCE: I mean his cellist
days are long and varied,
so yeah, we have plenty
of stories from them.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: Jenna and I
used to play together.
She's an incredible violist.
Does everyone know that?
She's such a good violist.
And also, like,
annoyingly, somebody
who's very good at both things.
Like-- your-- well, anyway.
SPEAKER 1: Jen is annoyingly
good at a lot of stuff,
actually.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: Yeah, so I
started as a cellist
and did that for a
long time and then
had the thing that I think a lot
of our musician friends have,
which is that the
training is very
different than the actual life,
the living of being a musician.
And so at a certain point,
I had been gigging and doing
orchestra gigs and
that kind of thing
and just sort of had
enough awareness to be,
like, I don't think this
is going to sustain me
for the rest of my life.
And then the cool
thing about radio
is it's kind of an
island of lost toys,
like, there's a lot of people
who started in one thing
and sort of found
their way into radio.
And I think what made
the transition easier
for me is that I feel
like radio exercises
a lot of the parts of my brain
that I used as a cellist.
So you're not just
telling somebody's story,
but you are telling
it almost musically.
You have to have a sense
of pacing and dynamics
and sometimes literally
working with music.
And so radio kind
of felt like a--
it felt somehow like
a related jump-ish,
to feed this intellectual
part of myself
that I wanted to take advantage
of and then also still use
the musical part of my brain.
That being said,
I was very aware
that I was jumping
from a niche thing
that I probably
wasn't going to make
much money in to
another niche thing
that I probably wasn't
going to make much money in.
So there was a moment--
there were definitely
moments in there where I was
like, this is the stupidest
fucking thing I've ever done.
But it worked out OK.
But Kathy also--
KATHY TU: Same thing.
I was in another career,
and then I quit it,
and then we became friends.
SPEAKER 1: Are you
OK with sharing what
that career was before you--
KATHY TU: Oh yeah, I went to law
school, and then I graduated.
And then I was, like, don't
really want to practice law.
And I decided to go
to Transom, the boot
camp where Tobin and I met.
But it's sort of similar
in that I've always enjoyed
detailed things.
And so law was great for that.
And now, the way Tobin
and I work together--
he's such a big picture
guy, about structure
and how a story
should fit together.
And I'm more about the
intimate details of when
a piece of music should start.
Should it move over
just a microsecond?
Or whether this cut
works because it doesn't
sound natural to my ear?
And we tend to-- we fit
together, like a puzzle piece.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: I'm curious.
For a lot of us
who are exploring
what it is like to be--
and this probably hearkens
back a little bit to the Out
at Work project, but
are sort of exploring
what it's like to be out
in one way or another
in the workplace.
And I think that we're
very lucky in many ways
here at Google in
comparison, particularly,
to some of the places that I've
been where I was really not
able to be out, that
we have a pretty
supportive company and a
supportive community here.
I'm interested to
know if you came
into any personal
conflicts or challenges
with moving into
the space of being
sort of professionally out.
Was that scary?
Were you worried about
putting yourselves
into this sort of semi or very
public space and any backlash
that you might get?
KATHY TU: I mean, I
was nervous about being
a semi-public person.
But that's just a
personal anxiety thing.
I'm a privacy nut.
So that was weird.
Did you have any?
TOBIN LOW: Yeah, well,
I think one thing we
both talked about is that we--
I don't think we ever wanted to
go into this suddenly becoming
like the voice of the gays.
Do you know what I mean?
Or like, the queer voice.
So I think there was a
moment where we were, like,
if we do this show, and we
don't do it the right way,
it's going to come off as if
we think we know everything,
or like as if anyone who's on
the show is an expert somehow.
And I think one of
the blessings of being
able to do stories is
that from the jump,
you're starting from
this is this person's
personal experience.
They are speaking
from what they know
and sort of telling
their piece of it.
And so once we sort of figured
out-- like, oh, as hosts,
we can do that also.
We can say we don't
know all the answers.
Part of this show
is, like, trying
to figure out some
answers, or figure out
a piece of an answer.
I think that was an--
but there was a lot of fear
at the beginning of ever being
booked on a, like, CNN
new show as a talking head
and, like, this
queer thing happened.
What do the queers think?
KATHY TU: Thoughts?
TOBIN LOW: Tobin and Kathy,
tell us what all of you think?
[LAUGHTER]
And that's very much a thing
we immediately moved away from.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
Yeah, no.
TOBIN LOW: The other thing
is that now my mom sends me
every article she reads that has
a remotely queer thing in it.
So it's, like, such and
such gay person did this.
KATHY TU: On the
flip side, my mom
thinks I'm doing an
internship in New York.
Because she doesn't
understand radio, and she is,
like, devastated
about this law thing.
[LAUGHTER]
Very devastated.
Every conversation
is, like, when are you
going to take the bar exam?
Eventually, I will.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, no, she
still thinks you're
going to take that bar exam?
KATHY TU: I promised her
I would at some point.
TOBIN LOW: Sometimes
you're, like,
I should just take
it to appease her.
I'm, like, that is insane.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: On that note,
do you feel comfortable,
and you can certainly
say no, sharing
your stories about coming
out to your parents
and what that was like?
KATHY TU: Do you want
to share your story?
TOBIN LOW: Sure.
I came out to my parents--
this is covered a little
bit in our first episode.
It's covered a lot a bit
in our first episode.
But if you haven't
heard, I came out
to my parents Thanksgiving break
of my freshman year of college.
And my mom's reaction
was basically like, well,
as long as we're sharing, I
think you've gained weight.
[LAUGHTER]
Was, like--
KATHY TU: Your mom's the best.
TOBIN LOW: --reaction
number one.
SPEAKER 1: Damn, Mom.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah,
yeah, she immediately
went back to the truth bombs.
KATHY TU: Yeah, she's
still dropping them.
TOBIN LOW: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that was her.
And then my dad, we
had this funny thing
where he at the
time was obsessed
with "Queer Eye for
the Straight Guy,"
which I had very
complicated feelings about.
I didn't really see
myself in that show,
and I didn't really feel it
helped me figure out myself.
But for my dad,
it was this thing
where that same year he had
seen "Brokeback Mountain,"
and I had asked him to see it.
And his reaction was, like,
why did you ask me to see that?
It's a story about how that can
be hard and ultimately deadly
for some people to come out.
And so it was this weird thing
where his fandom of "Queer Eye"
actually helped him a lot.
Because it helped
him imagine that I
could be a happy adult person
who is leading a full life.
Even though those guys
were, like, literally,
redecorate your
apartment and then leave.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHY TU: Would you call
them literal fairies?
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: Yeah, there
was an aspect where
you don't have to engage
in their rights, just let
them paint your walls.
KATHY TU: And get out of there.
TOBIN LOW: Now leave.
So anyway, we had this funny
thing where I hated the show,
he loved the show.
But it became like a
translation tool for us.
So that was kind of
my coming out thing.
KATHY TU: I think I had a
more classic coming out.
I came out to my mom, my
parents, both of them.
And then my mom screamed
at me over the phone.
And then I tried it again
later, and she didn't talk to me
at all about it.
And then I went to
Burning Man, and I
had a moment at the
temple, in which I was,
like, I got to do this again.
So then I came out again
to my mom, and I brought--
at the time, I thought it
was a translation issue.
I thought if she understood
what I was actually saying,
then she wouldn't feel
the way that she does,
which was completely wrong.
She absolutely feels-- she
understood the whole time.
And she was not OK with it.
And we had this conversation,
and I recorded it
because I felt like every
time we talked about it,
it just went away, and it just
wasn't going to be around.
And I wanted to acknowledge
that I had come out to her.
So to me, I didn't
want to feel insane.
So I recorded it.
And then it became the
basis of our first episode.
So really, the podcast came
around because of Burning Man.
TOBIN LOW: Oh god.
If that's true,
I quit right now.
But what did you use to make
sure that she understood you?
KATHY TU: Google Translate!
SPEAKER 1: Hey.
[APPLAUSE]
Man, we've got Docs,
Translate, Reader.
KATHY TU: You guys, I
don't have my phone on me.
SPEAKER 1: You
should just move in.
KATHY TU: I love the Google
Pixel, if anybody has--
TOBIN LOW: Now we're
just pandering.
KATHY TU: --information
about Google Pixel 2--
TOBIN LOW: Now we're
just pandering.
KATHY TU: --I would
love to hear it.
SPEAKER 1: Me, too.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Actually.
KATHY TU: That would be great.
Thank you.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Anybody
else have questions?
I'm taking up--
KATHY TU: Also Google Fiber.
I can't wait for that.
SPEAKER 1: Google Fiber.
I'm on the Fiber team.
We were talking about it before.
KATHY TU: I use Google Domains.
Like, I am all over Google.
TOBIN LOW: Now she's
just trying to get a job.
KATHY TU: We were just
talking on the train over.
You guys should
start Google Resumes,
and let that be
the new LinkedIn.
Anybody?
SPEAKER 1: You are giving
away all of your good ideas.
KATHY TU: I know!
When this thing implodes,
like, I want to work here.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry, Tobin.
No, anybody?
TOBIN LOW: Well, that--
OK so, I'm curious
how often people
think that you guys
have insane technology
and actually are, like, well--
that's a ways off.
Probably you can't
answer that question.
It's a curiosity that I have.
SPEAKER 1: Is
there anything else
that you'd like to share with
all of us before we wrap up?
KATHY TU: I'm not joking
about working here one day.
[LAUGHTER]
TOBIN LOW: OK, easy.
SPEAKER 1: We'll stay in touch.
We'll stay in touch.
Yeah, anything else you'd like
to share about the podcast
or about your experience
with the podcast?
TOBIN LOW: I would
just, again, plug,
if anyone has interest in
filling out our survey,
we really are just fascinated
by people's stories
and want to collect
as many as we can.
And it helps the project be
more representative, too.
So NancyPodcast.org/Work.
KATHY TU: Yeah, if you
share with your networks.
SPEAKER 1: Now I kind of want
podcast to be my full-time job.
[LAUGHTER]
Talking about queer things
and answering people's pitches
for stories.
Does anyone have any pitches
for stories while we're here?
KATHY TU: Ooh,
live pitch session.
SPEAKER 1: Live pitch
session happening now.
KATHY TU: I don't
think I could do that.
SPEAKER 1: No?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 1: Can you
pop up to the mic?
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
TOBIN LOW: Aw.
SPEAKER 1: Sorry.
KATHY TU: But look
at that bow tie.
AUDIENCE: Or
Pennywise from "It."
TOBIN LOW: And [INAUDIBLE]?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KATHY TU: No, I haven't.
AUDIENCE: Do you like
[? Bubble ?] [? Wise ?]
and they're dating.
And they like to wear
extravagant clothing,
and, like, kill children.
Like there's a whole thing
you could do on this.
TOBIN LOW: So here's the thing.
There are so many
gay Twitter things
that I would love
to do a story about.
But it moves so fast.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, for a second
I was, like, we
have to do a Park
[? Stinton ?] thing.
But I don't know if anyone
is familiar with the Park
[? Stinton. ?] It was
like some fake twink
on Twitter catfished
a bunch of guys.
And it was, like, gay
Twitter blew up about it.
And then it disappeared
within a day.
Anyway, this is all to say, yes.
I am hungry to do
something about it.
It's a challenge,
because it moves so fast.
But it's fascinating.
Yeah.
KATHY TU: So yes.
TOBIN LOW: We can be quote
unquote [? "baba ?] shook."
I sounded so uncool saying that.
SPEAKER 1: How long
does it usually
take you to come up with an
idea and then record the podcast
and then get it out?
What is that timeline?
KATHY TU: Oh, it depends.
SPEAKER 1: So that
we know, in case we
want to pitch any stories.
We know when to look for it.
KATHY TU: It really depends
on when we start working on it
and then how we see it
fitting into our schedule.
Like, "The L Word"
story started right
at the end of the last season.
Because I was on vacation
when I started watching it.
And then we had to turn it
around within a few weeks.
But we've had stuff, like,
our Orlando episode took
six months, I think.
Because we went there, and
then we did all the recordings.
And then we came back,
and we had so many hours
of tape to work through.
TOBIN LOW: We had
16 hours of tape
when we came back from that.
And then that got cut down
into a 40 minute episode.
So that one was, like,
yeah, like six months
to get that one done?
KATHY TU: Maybe on average,
like, six to eight weeks.
I'm not sure.
It really depends.
SPEAKER 1: So not
Twitter timeline then.
That's like--
TOBIN LOW: It's hard.
It's tough.
KATHY TU: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: There and gone, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: A huge thank
you to you both for coming.
A huge thank you to
WNYC Studios, also,
for being amazing and
bringing these folks in.
[APPLAUSE]
Huge round of applause.
KATHY TU: Thanks.
TOBIN LOW: Thank you
so much for coming.